(gentle music)
- So if you're trying to
communicate a complex topic,
such as mathematics or
a mathematical problem
to the general public,
who might not be familiar
with the specifics
behind that problem,
there are many different ways
to help you get that concept across.
And one of the ways that we do this
in mathematical is to use videos
and things that are visually
appealing to people.
So by using lots of visual aids,
so bright colors and cartoons,
and word prompts on your screen,
you can engage and capture
the audience in different ways
that you might not be able to do
if you're just speaking
in terms of equations and mathematics.
- When we're more creative
about how we present and
how we talk about math
it makes it more relatable
to people from a variety of backgrounds
and cultures and experiences.
When we are creative
in how we explain or how we
relate mathematical concepts,
we can use things from
sports, entertainment,
or real world to help
really ground the principles
that we're learning
and the theories that we're
learning to something relatable.
So the more creative we can
be in explaining how math
is related to the world around us,
how it's related to things
that we are invested in,
the more likely it is to resonate
with the people around us.
- As soon as a problem is posed
our instinct is to find the solution.
But remember, often there's
more than one solution
and usually there's more
than one path to it.
(gentle music)